et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
vrai gilles bourguignon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous au ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour des
interviews en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice veysseyre aux dons du groupe
ebra bonjour fabrice bonjour oriane les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence bien sûr par la crise
sanitaire et olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé qui alerte sur la santé
mentale des francs seraient qui s'est
significativement dégradée en ce sont
ses mots
il a annoncé que des psychologues
seraient recrutés 160 psychologue
supplémentaire est ce qu'il y aura
d'autres mesures prises par le
gouvernement sur ce sujet ce que vous y
travaillez oui le ministère y travailler
notamment aussi sur le public des jeunes
dont on parle peu même si c'est un sujet
que j'avais travaillé auparavant dans
d'autres associations le suicide des
ados c'est un vrai phénomène est donc
avec adrien attaque et d'ailleurs ils
ont hier été voir la plateforme fil
santé jeunes qui est une plate forme d'
aide psychologique
d'autres moyens sont aussi dispensés
pour les personnes isolées notamment
évidemment les personnes âgées comme la
croix-rouge aussi qui a mis en place un
numéro
bref nous essayons en tout cas de par
des billets différents de nous attaquer
à ce problème parce qu'évidemment c'est
une crise sanitaire
mais c'est une crise sociale aussi avant
tout qui génère beaucoup d'angoissé sur
l'avenir immédiat et plus lointain donc
c'est une
et puis aussi en profondeur parce que
vous savez que c'est un un sujet sur
laquelle la commission des affaires
sociales que je présidais auparavant
s'étaient attaqués aussi dans la mesure
où la psychiatrie en france manque
cruellement de moyens et donc c'est un
vrai dossier auquel on s'attache des
mesures particulières pour les personnes
âgées
d'une part et pour les personnes en
situation de handicap parieurs oui aussi
bien sûr parce que pour nous c'est un
tout et on va pas non plus morcelé
évidemment la tente où le de ces
personnes qui sont en droit d'être
épaulé donc à travers tous les
dispositifs dans tous que nous avons
même les aidant par exemple il peut y
avoir aussi des petites formations ou
des numéros qui leur facilite la preuve
je le vous l'avez dit
dans la conférence de presse en réponse
à emmanuel macron qui disait il est dur
d'avoir 20 ans en 2020 vous avez dit il
est aussi dur d'avoir quatre fois 20 en
quels sont les inquiétudes que vous avez
concernant les personnes âgées est ce
que ce sont des inquiétudes sur leur
santé mentale des phénomènes de
dépression des inquiétudes financières
peut être avec une paupérisation de ces
personnes âgées alors c'est plus plus
haut niveau moral aussi parce que vous
l'imaginez
ces personnes sont très souvent isolés
d'ailleurs pour leur sécurité
on préfère qu'elle le soit donc la
famille s'éloignait un peu d'elle en
établissement on a constaté aussi que
l'enfermement total qui a été la
première vague le choix délibéré qui
était celui de l'or les protégés de
manière sanitaire a fait aussi par
contre montre qu' on pouvait avoir des
syndrome de glissement assez fort chez
ces personnes certaines se sont laissés
complètement mourir donc tout ça on y
est maintenant très attentif dans la
mesure où nous avons tiré les
enseignements de cette première vague et
vous l'avez dit on va parler de cette
situation dans les ehpad 1 vous avait
alerté hier tout se joue maintenant vous
dites pour que la deuxième vague ne
ressent pas à la première dans ces ehpad
on a compris que la stratégie ne va pas
d'isoler noé mais encore ce n'était pas
la bonne stratégie est ce que néanmoins
il faut durcir les conditions de visite
dans les ehpad est ce que vous y
réfléchissez vous et bien sûr on a
d'ailleurs tout de suite dès la fin août
nous avons mis en place un protocole qui
a été adressé à tous les étages avec une
charte éthique que nous avons rédigé en
commun avec d'ailleurs une personne âgée
d'un d'une des résidences des éthiciens
d'autres psychologues sur le phénomène
d'enfermement dont je vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure qui avait suscité par endroits
des syndrome de glissement
donc nous avons partant de ce principe
nous avons essayé de trouver la bonne
ligne de crête entre ce qui relève de la
protection sanitaire pure et ce qui
relève aussi de la nécessaire vie
sociale que nous devons à tout prix
maintenir parce que d'abord c'est un
droit un droit des aînés qu'ils sont en
droit de réclamer et certains nous l'ont
dit en disant j'ai 80 présents
j'en ai assez je veux voir mes enfants
c'est mon anniversaire je ne suis pas
sûr d'en avoir un 14e écoutez moi donc
mais partant de ça nous avons trouvé
mais nous sommes en deuxième vague et
donc nous avons un personnel aujourd'hui
plus aguerris plus près finalement à
isoler à tester on y reviendra
et aujourd'hui donc avec un certain
savoir faire si j'ose dire dans à
l'intérieur de l'établissement
tout repose maintenant évidemment sur le
fait de protéger au mieux sans
recommencer cet isolement total et une
question qu'on se pose c'est peut-être
un peu naïve 1 mais vous avez donné hier
les chiffres des contaminations dans les
ehpad vous dites y'a un ehpad sur cinq
qui est touchée dès 1600 et pat qui sont
touchés et dans le même temps vous dites
on a on a acquis du savoir-faire les
personnels sont mieux formés il ya aussi
les masses qui sont là alors qu'il
n'était pas forcément là pendant la
première vague du coup on a un peu du
mal à comprendre pourquoi de tels
chiffres dans les ehpad un peu comme
s'il y avait une fatalité finalement ce
que les ai pas de soi autant touchés oui
d'abord il faut se souvenir de quelle
quelle personne nous parlons il s'agit
bien de personnes plus vulnérables que
les autres
on sait très bien aussi le taux de
mortalité a été beaucoup plus fort chez
les personnes âgées pas forcément celles
de plus de 80 on sait bien que ça
commence à 65 ans et c'est donc il faut
être conscient de ça c'est un public
plus vulnérables plus sensibles que les
autres probablement au virus est en tout
cas quand il s'attaque à ces personnes
c'est beaucoup plus dangereux que pour
d'autres pour autant on peut pas se
satisfaire de ça et dire alors on les
copines totalement 1 à régler le
problème
ça c'est insupportable pour elle surtout
et si on les écoute et moi je veux les
écouter parce qu'elles ont des droits
qu'elle revendique
elles disent je ne veux pas être enfermé
comme on entendu parfois dans d'autres
reportages comme dans une prison
donc il faut pour le coup deux phases
c'est à dire empêcher l'entrée du virus
dans les établissements au maximum
sachant et soyons humbles que le risque
zéro n'existe pas angela du risque zéro
anglade sur scène tous les we un ehpad
sur cinq touchés d'autres établissements
sont touchés on en parle moins
mais un public qui est plus vulnérable
donc il faut redoubler de protection dès
lors qu'un cas arriver quand on parle de
clusters il faut aussi faire attention à
ce qu'on dit cluster on a l'impression
quand on dit que le store c'est tout
l'établissement qui est touché un
cluster c'est à partir du moment où il
ya trois cas qu'ovide dans un
établissement
quand je dis il y à 1600 cluster je
préfère dire il y à 1600 établissements
avec trois cas qu'ovide au moins donc
considéré comme cluster bien sûr dans
ces établissements il y en a qui ont
beaucoup plus de cas que d'autres et là
il ya une attention extrêmement
particulière avec des ars qui redouble
d'efforts et de vigilance sur ces
établissements là des renforts qui sont
envoyés dans ces moments là j ai nist
psychologues etc pour faire attention à
ces personnels ou est ce qu'il ne faut
pas s'attendre à des moments plus
difficiles qu'ailleurs pour la période
de noël notamment
c'est un moment alors de famille oui
c'est un moment de famille que nous
devons respecter moi pour moi quel que
soit le public et je comprendrais mal
que nous ayons des mesures complètement
discriminatoire si on disait bon ben
voilà on va enfermer les personnes les
plus vulnérables a dans ces moments de
fête parce que comme ça il y aura moins
de propagation alors qu'on y arrive là
en ce moment ça se diffuse on le sait
mais aujourd'hui il y a un savoir faire
et aujourd'hui l'apport de ces tests
antigénique dont une parleront peut-être
mais on va reparler tout cela permet
d'isoler beaucoup plus vite mais c'est
qu'à un mot juste avant de parler des
tests chimiques sur le nom de 17 au tad
totale du coc vide a annoncé combien
sont son bébé sept qui sont dans les
ehpad en pourcentage je ne sais plus le
chiffre et on était de 30% non c'était
oui à peu près 30 9% entre 9% et 11% est
presque mais il rentre mais encore une
fois partons du principe que ça n'est
pas relatifs à des établissements mais à
un public et que c'est bien un public
âgé qui a tout de suite été répertoriés
comme le personnes les plus vulnérables
et les plus atteintes avec des
conséquences plus lourdes que quatre que
d'autres plus petits car j'aime sur elle
en a vu qui était guéri dans des ehpad
que j'ai pu rencontrer avec lesquels
j'ai pu discuter qui nous rassure aussi
sur sur cette maladie
on va parler de ces tests justement ces
tests antigénique et puis hier vous avez
dit que vous
en béotie des tests pour les visiteurs
trois des tests pcr soit des tests
antigénique fait le jour même et vous
dit-on les recommande pour pourquoi ne
pas les rendre obligatoires et ce car si
réfléchissez à ce que c'est de l'ordre
de parce que la notion de d'ehpad
il me semblait un peu galvaudé dans
l'opinion publique
un ehpad c'est pas un hôpital un ehpad
c'est un établissement d'hébergement qui
est plus sécurisant parce que on a
atteint un degré de dépendance où on est
en perte d'autonomie et que la famille
ou la personne âgée elle-même décide d'y
résider et c'est ça qui fait la
différence à partir de deux seuls de ce
moment là on doit considérer non pas la
chambre mais une résidence à part
entière et à partir de là aussi vous
êtes chez vous et vous avez votre
famille qui veut vous rendre visite
c'est compliqué il faudrait dans ce cas
là qu'on établisse le fait que tout le
monde va aller se faire tester dès lors
qui va voir sa mère qui habite à
domicile au certaines régions comme en
auvergne rhône-alpes le fond de bonnes
généralisée vous n'êtes pas favorable
libre à elle mais on va encore retombée
sur le procès d'atteinte à la liberté
individuelle de chacun moi je pense plus
à la responsabilité de chacun chacun
sait vraiment je pense je connais des
familles quand elles veulent rendre
visite
alors venez dans les établissements le
fond ils se disent je ne vais pas y
aller parce que j'ai des symptômes donc
je préfère nous bien sûr toujours
s'appuyer sur la responsabilité de
chacun
ensuite sur les entrées dans ces
établissements c'est pas le moulin à
vent en ce moment au contraire il y à
des contrôles il y à des visites sur
rendez vous et les visites sont
organisées dans des sas dans des
endroits protégés
on ne va pas dans les champs aussi on y
va c'est avec vraiment des protections
parce que la personne ne peut plus
sortir de la chambre
tout ça est vraiment proportionnée et
c'est cette notion de proportion de
mesures qu'il faut toujours avoir en
tête pour regarder vraiment à la fois
cette ligne de crête qu'on s'est fixés
entre la liberté individuelle la
protection sanitaire que nous devons à
nos aînés mais aussi le fait que les
visites ne soit plus interrompu et le
lien surtout le lien social
un mot sur le vaccin brigitte
bourguignon il ya des perspectives ainsi
optimiste en tout cas sur le vaccin est
ce que les personnes âgées et
et personnels soignants seront
prioritaires et est ce que le vaccin
sera obligatoire pour eux alors sur le
caractère obligatoire
vous savez bien que c'est un débat
permanent et que non il n'est pas
obligatoire sont des personnels
c'est encore une fois et il ne le sera
pas un débat qui revient en dehors de
cette crise sanitaire d'ailleurs moi je
l' ai vécu souvent même en cours de
pelles fss parfois on dépose des
amendements en ce sens et ça n'est
jamais accepté voilà il y a des règles
il ya des discussions il ya des
partenaires sociaux aussi qu'ils sont
dans la négociation de ce genre de deux
procédures et puis après ça relève bien
sûr de seconde nous on propose en tout
cas dans les ehpad
c'est que une campagne de tests soient
faites tous les quinze jours environ
entre que tout le personnel qui est
d'ailleurs tout à fait adapté à la
situation et ils sont ils sont
consentants selon ce même personnel est
en difficulté actuellement ne serait ce
parce que le nombre de tests s'est
développée donc que des cas d'être isolé
cette épidémie mais met au jour met en
lumière quand même un certain nombre de
difficultés de recrutement
est-ce que sur le sujet vous assure vous
avez les plans alors il y a les ehpad en
aidant les épargnants notamment dans les
ehpad mais aussi dans le domicile parce
qu'on parle peu du domicile et si on
veut bien analyser les choses jusqu'au
bout de cette problématique des
personnes âgées
vous avez 60 % des personnes âgées qui
sont à domicile et 40% à peu près un
établissement on parle toujours plus tôt
des établissements hors qu'on s'adresse
à vrai dire on est en grande dépendance
à peu à peine à 10 % de la population
des personnels donc ça veut dire quand
même qu'on s'adresse beaucoup plus
souvent aux établissements alors que le
domicile c'est là où les personnes âgées
sont le plus souvent répertoriées et
dans ces deux structures en c2
monde que sont le domicile et les ehpad
nous avons un manque cruel de personnel
il est structurelle et conjoncturelle
conjoncturel là parce que comme vous
l'avez dit nous avons des cas qui sont
obligés de s'isoler des personnels qui
le protocole est applicable aussi oui
dans les ehpad bien sûr de la manière
bien sûr mais mais le problème que nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est d'abord la crise
et donc nous déployons avec mes
collègues
brigitte klinkert saraiva elle est riche
elisabeth bornes jacqueline gourault on
est en train de déployer tout un arsenal
de tous les métiers contrats aidés
toutes les sources qu'on peut trouver
pour venir en aide dans pendant la crise
à ces ehpad par exemple dans
l'organisation des visites dans
l'animation sociale des établissements
moi j'ai demandé à sarah de travailler
sur les service civique qui pourrait les
chargé de la jeunesse au gouvernement ou
à lille et ça permet en tout cas cet
inter générationnel que nous voulons
faire naître dans ces établissements
c'est très important si le regard qu'ils
portent eux-mêmes sur les personnages et
donc d'abord cette ressource
ensuite les pôles emploi nous avons
adressé une circulaire à toutes les
directions pôle emploi et au préfet pour
mobiliser toutes les ressources et les
contrats que nous pouvons trouver pour
venir en aide mais ça c'est pour ça va
résoudre le problème conjoncturel de la
région problème je jure elle a également
eu aurait évité bien sûr il va être à
deux choses il y a eu un manque
d'investissement dans ce domaine depuis
15 ans et nous souffrons aujourd'hui
dans l'urgence en plus de répondre à
cette crise et nous travaillons sur la
loi grand âge que je prépare mes en
amont aussi un plan métier pour
l'attractivité des métiers que ce soit
aides soignantes auxiliaires de vie et
ce plan d'attractivité ans on inspire
avec le rapport et le comme ricky avait
été rendu
il ya quelques mois et bien sûr on ne va
pas réinventer la poudre parce que les
constats on les a tous partagé
l'attractivité ça tient lieu du salaire
donc on travaille sur les salaires on
travaille sur la prime par exemple il a
fallu que la rendre un peu plus
universelle qu'elle ne l'était puisque
nous ne sommes pas les mêmes financeurs
le domicile c'est le département le
sanitaire c'est l'état et tout ça a dû
se conjuguer pour qu'on arrive à faire
quelque chose d'homogène est universel
ça nous a demandé un peu de temps et
puis ensuite maintenance sur la
renégociation salariale avec le ségur de
la santé nous sommes déjà sur 7 sur ce
but de revalorisation salariale pour les
personnels des ehpad notamment puisque
là on a possibilité de le faire de
manière directe et le ségur l'acte est à
la fois sur leur vélo salariale à la
fois aussi sur le recrutement en
encadrement parce que ce dont souffrent
ces structures
ces deux taux d'encadrement suffisant
aussi voilà partout où il ya des manques
de psychologues de d'hygiéniste parfois
hélas cette crise sanitaire l'a révélé
de médecin coordinateur ça c'est très
important d'affirmer air de nuit parce
que ces établissements manquent
cruellement en tout cas partout où on
pourra faire en sorte que ces
établissements réservés aux personnes
âgées d'aujourd'hui s'ouvre parce que ce
don parfois nous avons souffert c'est
d'établissement trop fermé un peu opaque
pas assez de liaison avec les familles
pas assez d'explications
tout ça doit être ouvert aujourd'hui
ouvert aussi aux structures à domicile
pour qu'on arrête de structurer les
choses de limiter les choses de faire en
sorte que les gens soient morcelé dans
des dispositifs et justement brigitte
bourguignon puisque vous parlez des
familles on va parler du rôle des
familles lui est ce qu'un ce modèle dont
vous parlez et que vous essayez de
clarifier pour sortir un peu de cette
opacité
c'est le modèle de demain
oui au retour des personnes âgées dans
les familles en fait ce que veulent les
gens c'est rester chez elles elles
veulent rester à leur domicile
on ne pourra pas trouver une belle
politique domiciliaire de cette approche
sollicité par les personnes âgées sans
travailler avec les territoires déjà
tout ça est bien que ça ne peut venir
que des territoires donc on doit
travailler avec les collectivités avec
les départements pour que chacun imagine
les personnes âgées au sein de leur
village au sein de leurs de leur ville
et non plus imaginer des établissements
hors de la ville avec toutes les
problèmes de mobilité que ça pose
notamment pour ce public on doit ré
imaginer tout ça les ehpad doivent être
de lieu ouvert où il y a encore de la
vie sociale où il ya des boutiques ou
liées à il y en a ça existe déjà moi je
vais rencontrer tous ces ehpad les ehpad
hors les murs aussi c'est à dire qu'il
ya des ehpad avec des équipes mobiles
qui peuvent aller à domicile le plus
loin possible le plus longtemps possible
parce que c'est le soit mais il faut
travailler sur les logements en question
de très cher tout ça c'est très cher
mais je pense qu'avec tout ce qu'on met
en ce moment sur la table dans le plan
de relance dans le la rénovation
énergétique parfois bon les
collectivités là sont prêtes à s'en
saisir je crois et avec quand même un
enjeu majeur c'est de se dire que ce
n'est pas que le risque écologique mais
le risque aussi aujourd'hui c'est le
vieillissement de la population la
longévité
nous sommes pas régie pour avoir donc
rendre une longévité suisse étant
justement la loi grand âge pour la
première fois dans le plfss il y avait
cette 5ème branche mais vous l'avez
entendu les parlementaires se pose des
questions sur son financement le
gouvernement avait promis une conférence
de financement en septembre elle n'a pas
eu lieu
est-ce qu'elle va avoir lieu et quand
alors moi je n'ai pas la date pour la
conférence de financement ce que je peux
vous dire en tout cas c'est que la
cinquième manche c'est quelque chose que
tout le monde voulait et qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde salue je n'ai pas entendu
sur les bancs on peut s'imaginer se
poser des questions sur le financement
sur il parle de coquilles vides certains
cas de mon coeur je les avais entendu le
dire mais hors dire aujourd'hui que dans
ce modèle de protection sociale ont créé
une branche qui correspondent un réel
besoin pour toutes les raisons qu'on
vient de se dire pour cette politique
sur
tourné vers les personnes âgées et les
personnes handicapées un jeu mais
personne de côté
cette branche de l'autonomie tout
simplement devait être créée et elle
l'est aujourd'hui félicitons nous en
aujourd'hui elle va permettre aussi de
construire cette politique publique qui
soit qui concerne combien de personnes
en france on peut le rappeler à je n'ai
pas chiffon en 2040 jours accueillera
près de la wii j'espère salage et il y
aura plus de personnes
bien sûr qu'ils auront plus de 75 ans
mais quand et où l'importance mais juste
sur le financement ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya pas de conférences de financement
prévu à l'heure actuelle non là je peux
pas vous dire qu'à une conférence de
financement maintenant parce que parce
qu'elle n'est pas elle n'est pas là moi
j'ai rencontré la scène et ça on
travaille bien sûr ensemble maintenant
sur notre schéma de développement et de
financement qui va se construire aussi
au fil de l'eau parce que vous vous
imaginez bien on a mis la première
brique avec déjà le h2 dans avec des
financements destinés le ségur de la
santé oms fait partie bref tout ça
construit cette branche et maintenant on
va construire aussi les dispositifs qui
vont dépendre de cette branche mais en
tout cas ça veut dire qu'on a identifié
ce risque si on peut appeler ça un
risque puisqu'il est inévitable de
l'autonomie mais qui peut conduire aussi
à d'autres personnes et c'est une
branche dédiée et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on maintenant et peut-être même qu'on
repense la protection sociale avec
toutes les branches différentes et
variées et c'est plutôt comme ça que moi
je l'envisageais en tout cas la loi que
nous construisons ça veut dire quoi
juste repenser la protection sociale
comment vous envisagez à titre personnel
je ne vous dis pas que je suis en train
de la repenser mais il faut qu'on mette
les choses sur la table les branches
différentes est ce qu'elles sont encore
d'activité est ce que certaines sont pas
obsolètes est ce que il faut qu'on
regarde ça mais en tout cas moi ce que
je vous dis c'est que cette branche
autonomie que nous construisons
aujourd'hui et a le mérite d'exister a
le mérite aux en tout cas de
correspondre à une vraie politique de
l'autonomie qui répondent aux besoins
des personnes handicapées et qu'ils
arrêtent de morceler aussi les gens qui
sont obligés de recourir les dispositifs
d'attendre que l'une caisse en voit
l'autre enfin bref vous savez bien la
galère que ça peut représenter pour
s'aérer un mot pour terminer de bruyne
le reste malheureusement qu'une minute
sur la loi grand âge dont dont vous
parlez on le disait il ya près de 15 %
des français en 2040 curan 75 ans ou
plus c'est une loi évidemment importante
elle très présente et quand conseil des
ministres alors normalement elle est
prévue dans le au printemps 2021 la
frise chronologique que j'ai donc au
prince tant au conseil des ministres
début d'année en conseil des ministres
de l'année pour un examen à l'assemblée
au printemps en tout cas nous y
travaillons sur les banques je vous ai
dit l'approché territoriale approche
domiciliaire sur ce que c'est ça qu'il
faut construire métier comme territoire
et puis les ehpad de demain puisque vous
ouvert à la société et surtout l'éthique
la dignité la citoyenneté et un autre
regard sur l'âge de début d'année ça
veut dire des mois de janvier oui mais
mois de janvier en conseil des ministres
au cache pas qu'on y travaille déjà
oui oui elle et elle était probablement
avant la fin de l'année d'ailleurs un
pari mais neil mac ont elles été promise
en dc avant décembre 2020 elle était
promise mais en même temps on n'avait
pas un ministère dédié
ça a été un premier signe qui a été
envoyé des mois de juillet et puis
ensuite vous savez comme moi il se passe
des choses dans ce pays qui se trois
urgences on voit là et notamment avec un
public et en plus mais votre cas au
coeur de la crise merci beaucoup merci
madame la ministre est peut-être venu
nous voir on va regarder la une de l'est
républicain des journaux du groupe ebra
fabrice et johnatan lavalin qui est à la
une de l'est républicain
daval f1 reconnaît avoir voulu tuer sept
[Musique]